- So according to the centers for
disease control and prevention,
one in four U.S. adults
live with a disability.
Among younger adults, we're
talking students here included,
cognitive disability is most prevalent,
for the others it would
be mobility disability.
But if you think about it, you know,
virtually every single one of
us can expect to experience
some form of disability in our lifetime.
And yet in our society and
societies around the world,
we have still a lot of wide spread
misunderstandings,
misperceptions, and stigma
associated with disability
and those who live with disability.
I'm Henry Kwan from the
Yale alumni association,
I'm delighted to welcome all of you
to our panel discussion today entitled
DiversAbility Addressing Disability Equity
Inclusion at Yale and Beyond.
This program is part of a
series events taking place
on campus, and off, this
month in observance of
National Disability Awareness Month.
This particular program
is collaboration between
the alumni association, the
Office of Diversity Inclusion,
and DiversAbility at Yale,
which is affinity group on campus
for staff with disabilities.
I want to take this opportunity
actually thank a few people
who helped make this program possible.
First is Melanie Norton who's
co-chair for DAY, Melanie.
(chuckles)
We also have Deborah Stanley-McAuley
who's the senior diversity
officer on campus.
I don't see her but I want
to thank her nonetheless.
And last but not least Miranda Monfilston
of the office of diversity inclusion.
Who actually took care of
most of logistics here.
So we hope that you will find
this discussion informative,
eluding and even perhaps inspirational.
But we're certainly delighted
to bring you this lineup
of speakers that we have here.
So please join me in a warm round
of applause for our speakers.
(audience applause)
- Henry I'd like to get
started with a microphone.
(audience laughs)
Thank you so much good
afternoon everybody,
my name is Janni Lehrer-Stein
I am Yale class of 78 Saybrook College,
anybody here from Saybrook?
Shout it out.
Really, seriously?
I'm from the best residential college
at Yale Saybrook College.
And it is really wonderful to be home,
my background is as an attorney,
I'm retired from practice.
I'm also a disability rights advocate
and a member of the disability community.
As you probably have
guessed from the presence
of the one who is undisputedly
the most adorable in the room
my guide dog Shiloh who is at my feet.
My disability is blindness
and I have the privilege of
being moderator here today
so we're going to do a little
bit of tactile interaction
when we get to the Q and A session.
Please just roll with me this
is gonna work out just fine.
I had the privilege of serving two terms
in the Obama administration
on the National Council of Disability,
serving as the senior
disability policy advisor
to the Hillary for America campaign.
And I currently am the vice chair finance
for the DNC Disability
Council as well as a member
of the National Board of the
Foundation Fighting Blindness,
and a member of the
National Academy of Sciences
Engineering and Medicine
forum on aging and disability.
We'll do some ground
rules as soon as we've got
everybody introduced and
I'm just so delighted
you could be with us today.
Sarah, I hope they've got one.
I'm not giving this up anymore.
(crowd laughs)
- Hi I'm Dr Sarah Poggi.
I'm here in two capacities.
I'll start with the professional one,
I'm a graduate of the
Yale School of Medicine
class of 1996 and I'm a
high-risk obstetrician.
I take care of pregnant
women with complications,
medical complications but
also genetic complications.
I do ultrasound and maybe
diagnose babies with problems,
and also in a consultative role,
I do medical malpractice
expert witness work on cases
where a child may have been born with
complications that are leading
to lifelong disabilities.
However the reason I am here
is more for a personal reason.
My medical school classmate, Dr Matt Poggi
and I married in 1995 and two years later,
he was diagnosed with multiple sclerosis.
He ultimately became quadriplegic
and from C1 down so he was
unable to feed himself,
really do any anything except
his cognition was excellent
and he died about six months ago.
So I'm here to speak I
guess as a caretaker,
talk about how it was
raising our two daughters
and at home and I actually
really happy to say
I have a daughter who's here
now and she is in Saybrook.
(crowd laughs)
To your point and I'm
going to end by saying
how I got on Henry's radar.
There was a veteran's,
Yale veterans event in Washington DC,
and my husband was a navy doctor
he did not step on a bomb in Fallujah
but he was a quadriplegic veteran
and he wanted to go to the event.
And like any good caretaker,
my first question was is it accessible?
And Henry found out that unfortunately,
for veterans was on the second floor
of an inaccessible building.
And I just expressed concern,
and maybe I was a little firm (laughs),
but I want to credit Henry
with coming back in spades
by saying wow, you know
we need to do better
for our our alumni that are disabled
in the community as a whole, thank you.
- Good morning my name is Jim Conroy.
I'm here from Pennsylvania
and I was here from 66 to
70 in Silliman college.
And I studied brain research
physiological-psychology.
My life got formed right after graduation,
my first job was a study
for a consulting firm
on the impact of a brand new law,
the Developmental
Disabilities Act of 1970.
And my first task was to draw a sample
of facilities nationwide to study
what would happen as a
result of this new law.
And drawing purely at random,
the first place to visit,
I drew a place called Pennhurst
State School and Hospital,
which is one of the most
notorious institutions
for people with intellectual
and developmental disabilities
in the world now.
And going there changed my life.
I was in the midst of
the women's movement,
the anti-war movement,
I was on a stage on May Day in 1970,
I was in the thick of
it but when I saw this,
these inhuman conditions,
I knew something had to be done.
And I've spent my whole life since then,
trying to figure out what to do.
But my role was simply scientist.
So I thought maybe somebody
who studied the human brain
could be useful in this field.
And I went to Pennhurst and found that
there's a lot to do.
In 1998 I went to Los Angeles
to visit college friends
and we decided to go
see the Holocaust Center
in which the first place I knew of,
that hands you an identity card,
and you go through not knowing
whether you lived or died
in the Holocaust until the end.
Three weeks later I woke
up back in Philadelphia,
in the middle of the night saying,
the disability rights movement
needs a place like that,
a place where we'll never forget,
where people can go by
the millions and learn
what's been happening and
I'm gonna try to convince
everybody for the rest
of my life probably,
that we need a place of memory
and learning in Washington.
There are four great civil rights museums,
one is in progress but
there are three that are
there in the mall now and
we'll be working for a fifth,
the forth well, there's
the Holocaust Memorial
Museum National and the,
Museum of the American Indian,
the National Museum of American,
African-American History and Culture,
and the fourth is in progress,
the National Women's History Museum,
which was, a commission
was set up in 2014.
The fifth will be, unnamed,
the National Center or
American Museum on Disability
Rights in history and
every disability group
will have to be represented,
it's going to take an easy ten years
but it'll be a good ten years
to devote to, thank you.
- My name is Sarah Scott Change,
I am the director of student
accessibility services
here at Yale we're the
office that works with
all students at the university
that register with us
and identify as having a disability.
I am not a Yale alum,
but I'm a Jonathan Edwards fellow,
which counts for something.
My background is as an attorney
but I've spent most of my career
working in disability issues in higher ed.
We work with students in
all issues of accessibility
here on campus.
Issues related to academic accommodations
to ensure that students
can access their courses
and their materials and
their handouts and readings
and powerpoints in an accessible way.
We work around issues of housing
and physical accessibility
of the campus infrastructure
which in the campus this old
can be a challenging task sometimes.
We work on issues around
transportation and dining.
And there's really no edge,
there's no boundary to what we do.
If we have a student
that has an accessibility
concern we just do a lot of creative
problem-solving to try to
find a way to meet that.
Sometimes we're very successful
and sometimes we're still working on it
and I'm very honored to
be here on this panel
with such great speakers.
- I'm Paige Lawrence I'm the
token undergrad on this panel.
(crowd laughs)
I'm the president of DEFY
which is Disability Empowerment for Yale
a student advocacy group.
And I run the disability
peer mentor program
which is in its third year.
We now have 32 mentees we
just got our latest addition
and we have 11 mentors.
So the program continues to
grow throughout the semester.
And I oversee all the matching
of mentors and mentees.
As DEFY president we you
know work to advocate
for the disabled community on campus.
We have events to build community,
we do advocacy and awareness work,
we've worked quite a bit with DAY,
and I also want to say on
behalf of the students,
we really appreciate what
student accessibility services
does and how hard Sarah
works for all of us.
So about myself and not so much
about the disability groups.
I am in Hopper College
formerly known as Calhoun.
So not favorite (laughs) yay.
And I'm a history and
new eastern languages and
civilizations double major,
studying egyptology in the ladder.
I plan to study the history
of disabilities although
we don't have a separate
disability studies program.
So I am sitting
disabilities in the context
of different ancient civilizations
and pre-modern civilizations.
I personally got involved with this
because in my senior year of high school
I was diagnosed with an immunodeficiency
which is a type of invisible
illness or chronic disability.
And as a results you know,
I've had to navigate the
bureaucracy of Yale Health,
getting approved for infusions
my freshman year of college,
now I receive monthly infusions
and I have to navigate
you know, my class schedule
around my infusion schedule
and it has really changed my life
and my perspective on you know,
how to stay organized,
how to deal with different
challenges as they arise.
It's totally changed my
perspective and as a result
I became very involved with
the disability community
on campus.
- Thank you everybody.
So as I stated previously,
it is my great privilege
to be the moderator
of the panel this morning.
So we're going to set a
couple of ground rules.
First of all even though I am here
to gently guide the discussion,
we want to make sure that
everybody's opinions are heard.
And so we're going to reserve some time
for questions and comments
at the end of the session today
and we encourage everyone to keep track
of what they would like to say
so that we have an opportunity to be sure
that every one of the room is heard.
Secondly it is part of my
responsibility as monitor,
to be the time police.
And because we have so much to discuss,
in this very broad topic
of disability, identity,
inclusion and accessibility,
both in terms of here at Yale
and throughout the nation.
We are going to keep to some
pretty strict time limits.
If an answer from anybody
in the room goes to more
than three or four minutes,
you will probably see me rise,
and gently stand next to
you or behind your chair,
that's the first hint.
The second hint is likely
going to be a little tap
on your shoulder hopefully
I'll be able to find
it but here's the kicker,
if you do not desist,
then the final element is on secret signal
to my four-legged assistant here.
Shilo is gonna kiss you all over your
face until you stop talking.
(laughs)
So with that said and
the ground rules set,
we have really a lot to discuss
and we're going to dispense
with the urban legend of age before beauty
and go right to our current
undergraduate student.
Paige thank you for being with us
and I'm wondering if you would
open the discussion with us
by just talking a little bit about what
you found the most surprising
thing good and bad,
when you entered Yale as a
student with a disability.
- Okay, thank you.
So I want to start off by saying that
when I was a first-year,
cause I'm currently a junior.
When I was a first year,
I was still navigating
the diagnosis process,
coming to terms with the
fact that I was now disabled,
this was lifelong, I would
have to receive treatment
for the rest of my life,
it's not something that would just go away
or be a temporary obstacle.
And for the first year
I was sort of in denial
that this was a part of my life.
I wasn't involved with the
disability community at all
but then my sophomore year I signed up
for the peer mentor program
and I found a lot of individuals
who you know like me,
have struggled with this new
identity of being disabled
or having a disability on this campus,
and who have faced different challenges.
And I very quickly started learning about
the other types of disabilities on campus
and how hidden or visible they are,
and how accessible this campus is
or sometimes the lack
thereof of accessibility.
You know how hard student
accessibility services work,
what the accommodations are in fact
I just learned last
week that there is a new
accommodation I could
have taken advantage of
when I was concussed last year.
So there are all sorts of resources
and I think what surprised me the most
was how decentralized the community and
the resources here are and
how hard it is to navigate
especially when you weren't
born with a disability.
Because for some of my peers,
who are born with their disabilities,
they've navigated their whole
life, it's second nature,
it's not this new additional challenge,
whereas for me it was just a whole new
world of figuring out how
it affected me personally
and figuring out how to
navigate on this campus
at the same time.
So I found that the
decentralization of resources
was the most surprising
thing on this campus
but then the most positive surprise
was how strong the community
of disabled students here is
through groups like DEFY,
the peer mentor group.
I had a fantastic peer
mentor my sophomore year,
I she's still one my best
friends, she graduated last year.
And she's the one who started
the peer mentorship program
just over two and a half years ago now.
And the the bond that we built
over the shared experience
of having a chronic illness
and being disabled on this campus
is so strong one of the
strongest bonds I think,
you can form is having
the shared experience
of being a disabled student on this campus
even if your disability
is wildly different.
It is still such a unifying experience.
So I was pleasantly
surprised by the strength
of the community and the
passion of the students
that I've been involved
with on this campus.
- [Janni] Thank you so Sarah Scott Chang,
that kind of leads us
into a lot of directions
in terms of your very important role
in assisting students at
Yale with disabilities
and also interacting with
the faculty and staff,
some of whom also are dealing
with the challenges of disability.
We heard talk about the diffuse element
of the disability community,
that's something that permeates
disability community nationally.
And we also heard a little
talk about the accessibility
issues that are certainly
profound when you're trying
to fully integrate
students with disabilities.
So could you tell us a little
bit about what your life
has been like assuming
the mantle of the head
of this very important department at Yale,
and what you have viewed as some of your
biggest challenges and successes.
- So our office has had
a lot of really kind of
radical changes over the last year,
that I think worked really
hard to increase our efficiency
and increase the
accessibility for students.
We just recently changed
our name about month ago
from resource office on disabilities
to student accessibility services
and we have had overwhelmingly
positive feedback on that and I think that
that goes a long way toward
increasing the visibility
of our office to students
that maybe we're not born
with a disability and are kind
of new to their diagnosis.
Also students with mental
health conditions that don't,
the word disability doesn't
really resonate with them
and it more accurately
defines the work that we do.
We work to create accessibility
and that's been a really good change.
We've increased a lot of
our internal efficiency
in ways that students very much appreciate
kind of brought our practices up to date
so students don't have to come physically
pick up papers from us every semester
and then physically take
them to their faculty.
We've gone digital and
paperless and that's been
I think a really good change for students.
Some of the challenges that we see is,
I think Yale has a culture
of perfection almost,
where everyone is expected to be perfect
in the thing that they do.
And there's not a lot of grace allowed
for people who are not perfect,
for people who are struggling,
for people who are still
trying to learn something,
and that affects the community
of students with disabilities
because there is the stigma
that if you have a disability
that's a weakness, that's a deficiency,
and I wholeheartedly do not believe that
but a lot of people do even
students with disabilities
have kind of internalized that idea.
So I think that there's a
lot of room for the campus
to grow and just be a
little bit more progressive
in terms of what disability means.
The people who say my
disability is my superpower.
I think there's a lot of value there
and just understanding that people learn
in really different ways,
that taking an exam that's
80 multiple choice questions
and that being the only grade for a course
might not be the best way to
evaluate a student's knowledge
of material every time.
And just kind of allowing
people to understand
that students can look a lot of different
ways and if it doesn't look the way you
are or the way that you expect
that doesn't mean that
it's necessarily bad
or worse or a weak or less,
it's just different and that's okay.
- [Janni] So thank you
so much for that comment
and we're already starting to see a couple
of themes emerge here in terms
of the fact that identity
in the disability community
is something that is
unique to every person
with a disability but also in terms
of the kinds of expectations and supports
and now the first discussion of stigma.
I'm gonna skip right over to
you Jim for just one second
because stigma has been raised as an issue
by Sarah to our other Sarah.
This is I think a rare
privilege on a panel
for us to have someone
who has sat with this
really many many hats and
vistas into the various elements
of the disability community
both as a family member
who has been so recently involved
in the end-of-life process
and I'm sure everyone here
agrees with me in sending
condolences to you and your
family for your recent loss.
Also as a physician who sees the side
of diagnosis and treatment.
In this case women with disabilities.
And we're over and I want to
get to this with my question.
A member of the caregiving
and supporter network
that surrounds people with
disabilities if they're fortunate
enough to have families.
So we know 61 million
Americans are challenged
by disabilities but that
number grows exponentially.
If you consider the family
members who are caregivers
and loved ones and supporters
and all of the work that they do,
that is usually largely uncompensated
and hardly ever recognized.
So Sarah could you talk
to us a little bit about
what your perspective is.
Is part of this kind of shadowy existence
behind the disability community.
- I'll say I was bone
tired for the four years
that he was quadriplegic.
I was the medical director
of my unit at work,
I did not miss a single day of work
because my income mattered
terribly to pay for his care
and we had basically I was
then the medical director
of a nursing home for one person at home.
And he was taking up to 35 pills a day,
I had six aides you know all
sorts of durable medical goods
that I was having to keep
track of you know things,
he was admitted to the hospital
I think 29 times in four years.
11 surgeries including an
amputation of his left leg
because of a pressure sore
because we couldn't get aides in
during a blizzard it was just,
it was a lot and at the same time
I have two girls that are,
one was in seventh grade
when he became quadriplegic.
The other ninth grade, the
girl who's now at Yale.
But I became a single parent for them,
he was of course present to them
and they would watch TV or do,
you know do things like this together.
But they say mom we were
down to half a parent
because we lost dad and you
spent so much time with him
that we didn't have much of you.
So I have some guilt right now because,
like I wouldn't have been
able to come up and do this
if he were alive I mean there's
an irony in all of this.
Because I always had to
have care for him set up.
I just know them because we
had had his diagnosis of MS
early and we were both physicians.
We had healthy incomes and we saved,
so we were ready for our rainy day.
It came earlier than we expected,
but we we could do it.
And I just fear for the people
out there that doesn't have
the resources that we did to
navigate the healthcare system
and have a nest egg to go into because,
we weren't bankrupt but I
mean we definitely took a hit.
I have, I don't know if any
of you have had someone like
this in the home but I have guilt
because I would get frustrated.
I would work all day,
come home you know, have to cook dinner,
feed him with my hands,
and sometimes I wasn't the nicest.
And I have a lot of guilt about that.
I'm trying to think what else to say.
I'm really proud I never put
him in a nursing home though.
I'm so proud of that.
- [Janni] So that's
maybe the best point for
us to jump off and talk about what Jim
has witnessed in his many years working
with the disability community and also
his aspiration to make sure that there
is Institute of learning where people
can come to understand
the disability community.
We have already heard
many of the major words
that are associated with our community,
inclusion, accessibility,
support, caregiving,
frustration, guilt.
So assuming that we get
this civil rights museum
up and going, in or around Washington DC,
what is the message that you
would like this institution
to send to people who are
not as engaged as we are
in the disability community?
- oh it's education, it's learning.
People don't understand, they don't know,
they don't know the
history of disabilities,
they don't know the pain of exclusion.
And I think if we had a place like the
National Museum of African-American
history and culture,
where millions of people come through,
it's the most record-breaking thing.
And as you said 61 million
Americans with disabilities
and their families.
This museum would be a big step
in learning to accept and include.
And that's the number one message.
It's not just learning,
it's actual action,
which is what the NMAAHC does.
It's it's not just learning about history,
it's taking action and changing attitudes.
- [Janni] So you used
one of my favorite words
which is action.
I'm sure everybody who has been
part of the Yale experience
and particularly those of us
who were students here at Yale
have some significant
memory of that aha moment
where a teacher really got through to us
with words that have stayed
with us their whole lives.
So you just mentioned one.
I was fortunate enough to be
a history student here at Yale
and my senior advisor
was John Morton Blum,
who is one of the iconic
history professors.
And in our first meeting
when I went shaking with fear
to talk to him about my proposal
for my senior thesis project,
he sat me down and he said,
I don't care what you write about,
I don't care how much you research,
you need to understand
that I will not tolerate
anything that is not in the active tense.
No passivity, no past
tense, no subjectives,
forget those rules.
I only want to hear from
you in the act of tense.
And I think that's what
you're talking about Jim.
So a number of years ago,
gonna go back to Sarah
Scott Chang over there.
Yale made a remarkable
statement in announcing
that they were going to
go completely digital,
in order to step towards full inclusion
for the yellow institution
and for their extended community.
And they are now requiring
that not only everything
on campus but that all of the vendors,
make all of their information
available in digital fashion.
This is good news for
someone like me who is blind.
But Sarah I wonder if you
could help us understand
what that means in terms of
Yale taking on a leadership
role and how that transition
is going currently.
- Yeah It means that a lot
of people are able to access
a lot of things that
they couldn't otherwise.
And I think that's a wonderful thing.
We have some of our digital
accessibility folks in the room,
Mike Vaughn and Michelle Morgan.
The CTL does a lot of things
working around accessibility
and they've been really amazing partners.
We work with students
for course materials,
we work directly with faculty
so that they can remediate
things on their end.
This can be people who have
been blind throughout their life
and rely on a screen reader like JAWS
that reads everything
they see on their screen.
It can also include students
who just got a concussion
and have an intolerance
for looking at screens
for the next three weeks,
and suddenly they're able
to listen to their readings
instead of visually
scanning it on their laptop.
And it's been really really amazing.
I've heard from a number of,
outside of the community people, vendors,
and just other people that
use different parts of Yale,
that the push toward digital accessibility
has been really helpful
on their end in being able
to access materials but also
in modeling that kind of best
practice behavior.
- [Janni] So along the lines
of best practice Paige,
I just want to know how that
best practice philosophy
feels to you as a person
who is engaged as a student.
And I know that the digital
element is not so much
associated with your personal experience
as a student at Yale,
but can you talk to us a
little bit about what the
disability culture is here at Yale
and how you feel inclusion
and integration exist
or is coming along for the
disability community of students.
- Yeah that's a big question
that we've been working on lately.
How to create this community at Yale
of students with disabilities,
and how to make it more inclusive.
So we've taken certain steps
like becoming affiliated
with cultural centers on campus.
We just affiliated with the
Asian-American Cultural Center on campus,
because we're trying to
be more intersectional
in our outreach.
We've worked with other student groups
that are not disability
related inherently,
but that do intersect with disability.
We've worked with
different faculty groups.
We've been reaching out to grad students
and working more with the graduate groups
and helping foster
graduate groups as well.
And overall we're just trying
to get everyone involved
in this community in the same room.
Because we've been so
fragmented empirically
that getting everyone in the same space,
on the same page even just in contact,
has been huge this year.
A new divinity school group is forming.
Currently a new graduate group
is hopefully coming soon.
There are a lot of new groups you know,
on the rise and working with DEFY,
the disability peer mentor program,
and we're also trying to create you know,
longevity for our groups a lasting impact
that will last even after I've graduated.
You know the founder of the peer mentor
program recently graduated
and handed it off to me
and we want to make sure that
there continue being these transitions
and that these programs don't just die off
once we graduate we want there
to be institutional memory
as well and you know another
way that we're working
together as a community is that we pooled
our collective experiences at Yale
and created a resource
guide to disability at Yale
it is a 26 page document viewable online
and for anyone who wants the
link I can give it to you
it's just tinyurl.com/disability@Yale
and it's this complete resource
using all of our experiences
with different types of
disabilities to help others
in our community understand what exists
and what communities
exists on this campus.
It includes a section about
different student groups
that are involved with disability.
There's you know a club that does ASL now,
there's all these different smaller groups
that are tangentially
involved in the community
and help build and grow
the network and outreach
that we have so we worked
very hard to reach a larger
portion of the student body,
and I think the peer mentor program
is the single best way in which
we've expanded our outreach.
And you know, last year
we had 20 some mentors
by the end of the year
this year we're in the 30s
and still growing, our mentees,
and we're still growing.
And I think that that
alone just says a lot about
how more people are getting
involved in the community,
more people want to be
involved in the community.
And I will say also on
the peer mentor forums,
when you fill out a form
to request a mentor,
there's a question that asks,
how much do each these
things matter to you?
And one of them is
connection with resources,
one of them is mentorship,
and one of the options is connection
with the broader community of students
with disabilities at Yale.
Most of the mentees, when
they fill out that form,
say that that matters the most to them,
connection with the broader
community here at Yale.
So it's clear that students
here want to be connected
with other students who like them,
have gone through the experience
of being disabled at Yale.
And people want to be a part
of a larger network here at Yale.
So we're working on building that network
the best we can because
it's clear that students
want to be a part of this network,
and want to be involved in these you know,
subgroups and this larger community.
So we're doing everything we
can to make this a reality.
- [Janni] It certainly
sounds like you are.
So I just want to do one
quick follow up question here.
It will count into your
rebuttal time don't worry.
(laughs)
You talked about doing
things the best you can,
and it certainly sounds
like they engaged effort
from the side of the students,
who are within the disability community,
is beyond anything I think
that I could possibly
have imagined all those years
ago when I was here at Yale.
But how is it really
in terms of acceptance
by the non-disabled peers
that you have at Yale?
Is it possible, for example,
for someone in a wheelchair
to be a member of one
of the singing groups?
Or on the stage at Yale Drama?
How easy is it to form
those personal relationships
to students with
disabilities date at Yale?
Just in terms of general acceptance,
could you give us some kind of a picture?
- Yeah so not to pull on specific names,
but the DEFY vice president and treasurer
are currently dating each other.
(laughs)
So I think people with disabilities
do date on this campus.
But more broadly speaking,
everyone in DEFY is involved with a lot
of other groups on campus.
In fact the vice president
and treasurer of DEFY
are involved in a production of
The Rocky Horror Picture
Show, I think in two days?
And so they're going to be
on the stage involved in that
and our treasurer is going
to be wearing a corset.
Our treasurer is a dude by the way,
just throwing that out there.
So the people in DEFY at the very least,
I know, are very involved
in lots of student groups.
You've got you know, someone
who's in acapella on campus,
we've got, you know a wide
range of representation
across the different
student groups that exist.
Music, arts, there's athletic involvement,
we have some club athletes.
So people are really getting
involved on this campus,
you know, regardless of whether
they have a disability or not.
And it seems that student
groups are generally
very supportive of having students
with disabilities in those groups.
So I think the culture on campus
is a lack of knowledge,
but a general willingness to support.
- [Janni] It sounds like
one of the characteristics
of Yale students everywhere
so thank you for sharing that
and here's the shout-out
to true love at Yale.
My husband and I, he was
Davenport class of 78.
We're married now 38 years.
So there is possibility for
life and marriage after Yale
even all those years ago.
(laughs)
I want to switch back to
Jim for just a moment.
Jim you in the class
of 70, me class of 78,
we're kind of rising seniors
in that very large perspective
of the journey of life.
What do you see as a potential
for some of us who have
had a lot of experience in this community
in providing expertise or just association
with the Yale community here on campus
or throughout the nation?
- That's a funny question for me,
I never took a history course in Yale,
I never took an English course,
I never took an art course,
I took all science.
And now I'm 70-years old and history
is suddenly fascinating,
(audience laughs)
I don't know what happened.
But my answer is it's to
provide that sense of,
what came before history.
I got here in 66 and I've been
wrecking my brains for years.
I can't think of anybody with any kind
of visible disability at Yale in 1966.
And yet, of course, mental
illness was underneath
many of our experiences and
some of my friends wound up
in bad places because of it.
But we have a history of
Yale that goes back further.
The American eugenics society,
from about 1870 to the
1930 the world was consumed
with eugenics as a leading
belief in social science.
Eugenics from the Greek
meaning good birth,
was the idea of the
people who are different,
people who were lesser,
than the master race,
should be eliminated from
the gene pool entirely.
That's eugenics.
The AES was on Elmen Grove,
the headquarters was at Yale.
So our history is long and grim.
And so really, I think those
of us who have been around
a long time can tell a
story of tragedy and triumph
because so much has
changed in our lifetime.
When I graduated, 1970, we
didn't have free appropriate
public education in American schools.
That happened because of a lawsuit
at that same institution,
Pennhurst in 1971,
called the right to education.
And it was won because children,
who were not allowed in public schools,
were being sent to institutions
at roughly adolescence.
The ARC, the Association
then for retarded children,
from Pennsylvania,
filed suit and won the right to education.
Four years later it was national law.
My children went to school
with all kinds of kids
and teachers with disabilities.
And it's made such a difference
in automatic acceptance
and the feeling of big deal,
that's I think where we want to get to.
- [Janni] So that leads us
back to both of our Sarah's.
I think let's start first
with Sarah Scott Chang
and your discussion about the work.
And we know that it's
hard work that you do
in order to ensure that students
with disabilities at Yale,
have the opportunity equally with students
who do not have disabilities to engage
and choose their classes
and really be fully involved
like any other student.
What we're looking at towards
that goal of full inclusion.
What would you say we need
to do on Yale's campus,
in order to get to that next step,
where inclusion is a given,
where as Paige has told us
it's easy for students with disabilities
to be in the broader community
for extracurricular activities,
but also in terms of the
core educational work
that goes on here.
Classes, studying, examinations.
Could you talk a little bit about that?
- Like Paige said,
I think that the people at Yale
want to do the right thing.
People want to be inclusive,
people want to be on the
right side of history,
and sometimes they just
don't know how to do that.
There was an amazing
panel last week with Paige
and a number of her student colleagues
on how to build an
inclusive classroom at Yale.
It was great and they talked about,
from a student's perspective,
what it means to be going to class
and have some assignment or materials
or whatever it might be
in your academic program that's there
but you can't quite access it,
because of the way the
professor is presenting it,
because of the requirements of the course.
And a lot of that could
be fixed if there was less
of a concern of this is the way we do it
because this is the way we've done it
for the last 300-years.
And more of a mindset of
how can I make my course
and this information
available and accessible
to the most number of students
in the most number of ways.
Because not everybody learns the same way
and if the goal of a class
is for students to learn
information and to have
mastery of that information
there's a lot of different
ways that that can be done.
So I would really love to see more
of an inclusion mindset across campus,
especially in the faculty
because I think they are
in a great position of power
and can model that kind
of behavior for everyone.
Students also, I think
students are naturally,
tend to be a little more inclusive.
Faculty, staff, everybody.
Just thinking about how
can we make this thing,
whether it's a class or a student event,
or a talk like this,
more accessible to more people.
- [Janni] So Sarah,
other Sarah, Sarah Poggi.
You've told us with such
great depth of feeling
about the frustration and the guilt
and also the cost involved
in caring for a loved one,
who is in the final stages
of dealing with a disability.
We know that this is true
throughout all of the stages
for a person who is
challenged by disability.
And I'm wondering if you could,
in your capacity as a
professional caregiver,
as a physician,
talk a little bit about
what you think could be done
in order to ensure
accessibility of medical care,
both in terms of the
availability of physicians,
physicians with disabilities,
and also the cost issues
that we're facing.
- So I take care of pregnant women
and I have taken care of women
with spinal cord injuries
who give birth.
And there's unique
considerations with that,
in terms of I work in a
hospital so my hospital
is completely accessible,
so that's not been a challenge for me.
But, may I mention the
discussion we had last night
about the mammograms?
This was actually something
that was brought on my radar
because it's not something I deal with.
But for example women,
when they have mammograms,
have to be standing and this is not,
having a mammogram device
that will accommodate
a woman who is seated is
not readily available.
And so this is the sort of thing that
needs to be on people's radar because
just because you're disabled
doesn't mean you can't get breast cancer.
So that would be an example.
What was the follow up of your question?
- [Janni] I was just hoping
you might also help us
understand a little bit about the cost.
This is a major discussion
raging across the nation right now
in terms of how we deal
with the availability
and cost of healthcare.
And perhaps you could share
some of your thoughts about
best ways to wrap the disability community
in a meaningful way.
- Well, everything's getting
dismantled right now,
it's terrible.
And I have patients that are,
I mean I practice in Virginia
which is not Mississippi
but I have patients
that have lost insurance
because of the dismantling of Obamacare.
And so people will
choose you know they may,
I'll give an example of a diabetic,
which isn't necessarily a disabled person
but they'll ration their insulin,
that puts a baby than at
risk for a stillbirth.
So I don't know what the solution is,
I feel like that's way above my pay grade.
Is there a way I could address those,
something he brought up with the eugenics?
- [Janni] Absolutely, go right ahead.
- So in my capacity as a high-risk OBGYN,
I feel like almost what you're saying,
what's old is new again.
ACOG the American College of OBGYN,
mandates that we offer
all pregnant couples
screening for 108 genetic diseases.
And so if a couple finds out
that their child may have this
and additionally we're
doing 18 week ultrasounds
to look to see if the
babies have birth defects,
the couples are now faced
with a difficult decision.
And these are births that would
have happened a generation
ago without anybody knowing
that they had a child
that might have a particular problem.
So I definitely, in the
privacy of my doctor's offices,
and seeing patients make
the decision to terminate,
children that would be
born with disabilities.
And that's a really complicated topic.
It was complicated for me
with a husband who is disabled
that I loved terribly,
but I have to of course be,
just provide support for whatever decision
and be in compliance with the law.
But I think there is a
movement for any of you
that have been pregnant recently
or have people that are
pregnant in your life,
you may be aware that this is--
The pendulums kind of
switching a little bit
with the science advancing,
with all the testing that
we can do on fetuses.
- [Janni] So the bioethics concern,
for people in the disability community,
is something that has
really been prominent.
Both in situations like
the one you're describing,
where people are being offered
or forced to make choices,
about welcoming someone with a disability
into the world and their family.
And also on the broader
topics that engage all of us,
healthcare, education,
transportation, housing,
perhaps most prominently in the news,
the discussion about the ethics
around self-driving cars,
we know that that would
be of tremendous value
to someone like me who is blind,
I haven't been able to drive
since I was 26-years old.
And yet there are ethical considerations
and push backs how these algorithms work,
in terms of making a
decision about what happens
if a collision has to occur.
Do you select to have less impact
to the car that has a baby
carrier in the back seat?
Do you decide that it's not so important,
if we know that the
driver is over the age of,
well in deference to Jim
and myself might say 85?
(crowd laughs)
These are very important
issues that might,
Henry, be the subject
of another discussion
at the Yale community.
Or perhaps among the alumni
to talk about the ethics
that are involved in these
very difficult decisions.
So we want to go to some
Q&A but before we do that
I'd like to engage with all of you,
in what I like to think of as
last round rapid-fire answer.
So get ready with one sentence or less,
as an answer to this question.
I'm going to start with Paige
and just move right across the panel.
And the question is this,
2020 marks the 30th anniversary
of the passage of the Americans
with Disabilities Act.
We literally have people
sitting at this table,
who lived most of their lives,
before that became a law,
and then we have Paige who
has lived her entire life,
the recipient of the benefits of that law.
So next year in 2020,
but then let's just push it ten years out.
In one sentence or less,
what do you want to see as
the most important focus
for the disability and engaged
community going forward?
Paige?
- It's rapid fire so in
lieu of a more, you know,
complicated answer I would
say a really important
element of the disability
conversation going forward
you know so in ten years from now,
I would really love to see
the focus of the disability
community shifting from
receiving accommodations,
to okay everyone's
accommodated the next step
is building better community
and making it so people
aren't afraid of disability
and being disabled
and this also goes back to
the eugenics conversation,
not being afraid to have a
disabled child for example,
like they are today.
Even with the existing
accommodations it's still so
stigmatized that people
are afraid of disability.
- [Janni] Sarah?
- So my answer is kind
of similar to Paige's
and that I would like to see a world,
where my office didn't need to exist,
where we didn't need
to make accommodations
because everything was universal
design and accommodations
weren't needed because everyone
could access everything
at any time might, be a few
more than 10 years from now.
(crowd laughs)
- [Janni] Jim?
- On September 6, 2018 the New York Times
published an article inopted
by five high school students called,
it's time for a national
museum on disabilities.
I give us ten years.
- [Janni] All right.
And Sarah?
This is real simple, don't
park in my handicap spot.
(crowd laughs)
When I got the van.
- [Janni] I echo that sentiment.
So you know as moderator,
I just want to first of all
thank all of our panelists,
for being just really both
attentive to the topic
of conversation and for
sharing your insight.
I want to answer my own question
in one word in 10 years.
I want to see us as fully included,
and I mean fully included.
So don't tell me you don't
want my dog in your restaurant,
don't kick me out of your Uber,
don't tell me that I can't
be part of a book club
even though I can no longer read
and I'm technically illiterate.
Just let us in.
So with that I'm gonna
ask Henry to come back
and steal my microphone
again so that we can take
some kinds of questions
- He's right here, oh.
(distant voice)
- Oh okay, what we got?
- Oh I'm sorry, guess I got confused.
- Any questions?
- [Richard] That was super.
I'm Richard Kane, med school 76.
I'm curious about the
educational piece at Yale.
We have Dean Chun here as well perhaps.
I'm just wondering if there is some room
in the curriculum in orientation,
at the med school are now
looking at putting disability
into the curriculum
there's a tiniest snippet
in orientation.
As a physician I was never
taught anything about disability,
I merely acquired it by
one-on-one experience.
Even how to deal with
people in wheelchairs,
there's literally no
teaching in Yale med school,
at this point.
So that educational piece I
think would be really important,
not only in the medical school,
but across all of the university.
and I would love to see that
opportunity to be developed.
- I'll take that.
Well I can speak to what
we do for education.
I am that little bit of education
at the med school right now.
I spent the summer going out
to all the different programs,
orienting the new students
talking about our office
and what we do,
reminding the medical students
that the disability exists
but I can't, I can't provide
the curriculum for them
and I agree that is something
that would be really great
because this is something that
as healthcare practitioners,
they're going to be dealing with probably
every day of their lives.
So we have have worked on
increasing our kind of community
outreach and getting students
as they come in the door,
to tell them who we are and what we do,
and not to forget that we exist.
But I think there's a
lot of room for growth.
- [Attendee] Yeah I definitely know
and was actually looking at
those, into the curriculum,
and the hiring of staff with disabilities
for including them.
- Oh great.
- I also want to add from
an undergraduate perspective
so not necessarily a
medical school perspective,
but in terms of you know
finding areas and ways
in which to learn about disability,
I found that I've had to
create the curriculum myself
within existing classes.
So as a history major, studying
history of disabilities,
I've taken classes on a
random ancient civilizations
where you know the the whole seminar
leads up to this term paper
on whatever topic you choose
within the field of study.
And I make that topic
paper about disability
in that ancient civilization
or whatever it is.
I try to apply it and I have to actively
you know, teach myself,
do that own research,
write the paper myself and
create that disability education
that I would like to have.
But I have found you know,
every year there's
usually one or two courses
often in the psychology department,
that talk about working with
children with disabilities
and I think that's about the extent
of the undergraduate curriculum
that is generally provided.
There's also history of
science, history of medicine,
in public health so HSHM, as a department,
occasionally talks more to disability
or mentions it in one
week of the entire class.
And so there are small
areas of opportunity
where if you are really looking
for it, you can find it.
Once per semester, one week per semester,
but there is no overarching curriculum
or waiver students not
interested in disability
to be exposed to it in an academic context
which i think is also very important
for normalizing disability.
- [Janni] So Paige, Sarah,
just to follow that up.
Do you think that it would be
reasonable to envision a day
where there is a major
disability rights and advocacy,
the way we've developed
majors for American studies?
- So I'll jump in really
quickly and say that
one of DEFY's long-term goals
is to get some sort of disability
studies program at Yale.
It's a very long-term
goal I know right now,
with ethnicity race and migration
that's been just a whole other topic
about you know getting that
approved as a field of study
and getting hiring power for the faculty,
and you know we would like ultimately,
have something similar
where disability studies
has like one or two faculty members,
over time even more,
and that students can study it.
Studying the history of disability
advocacy things like that
not just studying in a medical context,
as you know disabled bodies to be studied
from the medical perspective,
but as disabled individuals,
to understand, to learn about
to learn the history of.
And again it's one of our ultimate goals.
So I would like to see some sort of,
not necessarily major,
but a program of study here at Yale.
- I completely agree with Paige.
I think that it would go really really far
toward building community
and building that inclusive
ten year from now world,
where disability is just
another facet of life
and just another identity
that people can have.
Your question was whether it's reasonable,
I'm not sure about that
but I think it would be
a great thing to do.
- Well I think in terms of reasonability,
already we're seeing some support
from certain departments here at Yale.
Like women in gender and
sexuality studies, WGSS,
has been pretty supportive
and willing to potentially
include some disability
studies in their curriculum.
So that would be you know,
an avenue for us to pursue.
Would be starting out by having
disability studies offered
within a larger studies program,
and then eventually branching off
into its own studies program.
- [Janni] So I wanna
ask our friend out here
in the audience that raised a question.
What is been your experience,
in terms of people in
the medical community,
doctors, nurses, assistants,
with disabilities,
being part of the caregiving community,
and interacting with the patients?
Have you experienced that and
do you want to see more of it?
- [Attendee] Oh definitely
and there's a alum,
I think his name is Ryan
Martin and he is an OBGYN
who is wheelchair bound,
and he operates,
he operates doing OBGYN surgery
using a lift and they
have created a way for him
to do his practice despite his disability.
I've had classmates
with minor disabilities,
but I've also seen people at the school
who have more significant disability.
And the hope is that they
can continue to practice
and have the school accommodate,
have the patients accommodate.
I think when you have a
caregiver in a wheelchair
there's often a transfer
where people think that
the doctor has a bigger
problem than the patient does
and you really have to negotiate that.
I think that we have a lot to learn
and you know I'm excited that,
that we're talking about that today.
- May I address.
My husband worked for and
he had a cane like you did,
for most of his working
career as an oncologist,
and he switched from surgery
to radiation oncology
because he didn't have the dexterity.
But he worked for six months
in an electric wheelchair,
at my hospital,
and I would go empty his
Foley and give him his meds.
But his cancer patients
were so receptive to him.
I mean I think it was because they were
end-of-life patients themselves,
it was beautiful and then he
got too sick to do it anymore.
But he did not lose his practice,
and a quadriplegic and he
had to scribe and you know.
- [Attendee] Yeah, very courageous.
- Yeah.
- More questions?
- [Attendee] Thank you all so much.
Sarah, I love what you said about
sort of making your office obsolete
and I'm curious if part of that
is teaching students
the self-advocacy skills
to kind of know what
they need and ask for it
and how to do that.
- Yeah definitely.
I think that can be a really
big hurdle for students
to get over when they
first come as a first year
because the laws that apply
in the K through 12 world
are very different than the
laws that apply in higher ed.
And they go through K
through 12 with their parents
and their teachers and administrators,
just all knowing what the disability is,
knowing what the accommodations are,
and everything just kind
of happening for them
almost magically and then they get here
and cross some invisible line
that they never knew existed,
and then suddenly they have
to advocate for themselves,
and they're in our office crying
because they have no idea
how any of this works.
So we try to first off be
very patient and sympathetic
and understanding with students
when they first get here
because it's a lot to suddenly
have to advocate for yourself,
especially if you've never done it before.
It's intimidating, it's daunting,
I had a student break
down and cry one time
when she understood
that she needed to tell
her faculty that she used accommodations
and she just started crying and said
but he's a Nobel Prize winner,
how can I possibly have
that conversation with him.
So I think that is tough.
And then especially in the
realm of invisible disabilities,
there can be an extra
layer of difficulty there
because if you're having
conversations with people,
and they can't see and understand
that you're a person with a disability
and they just kind of have
to take your word for it.
Some people have a hard time with that,
and they really grapple with you know,
why is bipolar, why would
that be a disability?
Can't you just toughen up and get over it?
So being a self-advocate
in the face of that
can be really hard for anyone,
and especially a young person
who's also trying to come
to college and learn all the other things
that 18 year-olds are learning.
So I do think self-advocacy
is really important
but I also think that all the onus
shouldn't be put on the
student to do that, right?
There needs to also be,
kind of a culture change
in the community at large
that's more accepting of those things,
and more understanding of things
even if they can't see it.
- Anybody else?
- [Attendee] Hi I was wondering,
what percentage of the
undergraduate population
and you know, the other schools as well,
currently identifies as
a person with disability,
both physical or mental health problems?
And would you consider
that you are an underserved
or under, not underserved necessary,
but underrepresented minority at Yale?
And the point that you made about it,
being a place of perfection,
is that something that
prevents many students
who could contribute here
from even arriving on campus
and contributing in various ways?
- So we have about 10%
of the student population
registered with our office.
I don't really know the breakdown
for undergrad versus all
the professional schools
off the top of my head.
My sense is that it's about the
same across all the schools.
That 10% is students who
have a lifetime disability,
students who are new to a diagnosis,
like Paige was her first year,
students who got a
concussion a couple weeks ago
and are just dealing with that
for the rest of this semester.
So it's a really wide range of things.
Some use accommodations
throughout their entire time here,
some students use it just
for a kind of finite period
of time as they're recovering,
we have students that have
situations that are sporadic
and they might be heavy users
of accommodations one semester
and then not not want
anything to do with us
for the next year.
But generally about 10%
of the student population.
I do think we are under resourced.
(crowd laughs)
In this sense that there's
a lot of other work
that we could do.
As it is where we're we're
making accommodations
for things that come up, right?
So a student's in a class
and they have some material
that they can't access, so
we're working to make it so that
they can access that reading.
If we had more resources,
we could do more front-end work
and work directly with the faculty
and make sure that all
materials are going to be
digitally accessible for
all classes moving forward
so then we don't have to
do those accommodations,
case-by-case basis.
I think I'm trying to put
our office out of work
a number of times but I do
think that there's a lot of room
for that kind of extra resources
could help us do that work better,
and then also kind of to
what Paige has talked about,
there's a lot of community
building that needs to happen.
Our office is kind of more for compliance
so I'm not sure exactly where
the right fit is for that,
but I do think there's a real need for,
and a value in building a community
at the university generally,
and there's a lot of
room for growth there.
- [Janni] Sarah could you take
that just one step further
and the elephant in the room,
we really haven't talked a lot about.
Is mental health and mental illness.
We all know that suicide
is a crisis situation
in all campuses across the
nation and around the world.
And I have heard tell some
peer support groups hearing
at other universities.
Would you like to comment
on what your department
does in terms of helping
students in that crisis?
- So we're not mental health clinicians
and we like to make that very clear right?
We are not the kind of first stop.
If you're in a crisis,
then we will help you
get to the right people,
we'll help you get connected
with student mental health.
But that's not what what
we ought to be doing.
We do, are by far,
our fastest-growing kind
of percentage of students,
is students that identify
with mental health concerns.
And we are continually working
on building the community
and the relationship with
student mental health.
There's a number of student groups,
Paige would probably be
better equipped to talk about
this student groups that work
on issues around mental health
and peer counseling and just
kind of raising awareness
about mental health on campus generally
and I think that's really
important work also.
- Yeah so before I talk
about mental health,
I want to touch briefly
on the original question.
I just want to add that
not everyone who identifies
with a disability or who
requires accommodations
goes to student accessibility services.
A couple of, even my peer
mentees alone not even,
just like, looking at the whole program,
but just the ones who are my mentees,
have not been registered with
student accessibility services
and I've you know,
suggested that they register
and seek accommodations,
but not everyone with a
disability on this campus does.
So that 10% number it's
probably much higher in reality
in terms of how many students
need some form of accommodation,
have some form of disability.
I would also add that,
we also feel like student
accessibility services
does not have enough resources,
and we feel that as a community
we are underrepresented
on this campus in terms of you know,
professor's hearing our voices,
student groups having our involvement
or requesting our involvement,
or even taking into
consideration the accessibility
of the location of an event.
We put a section in the guide
for navigating disability at Yale,
that talks about social life on campus.
And you know, our
secretary of events, Aria,
she's fantastic, she is in a wheelchair
and she was talking
about the accessibility
of different frats only
one frat on this campus
is wheelchair accessible, for example.
And the fact that that you know,
came into conversation in our
group is just very interesting
that you know, none of these
fraternities sororities have
thought about accessibility
of their locations.
A lot of these social groups
that occur off campus,
a lot of the events that occur off campus,
are not in accessible locations
and just the lack of involvement
and requesting of disabled
voices in some of those areas,
has made it so we can't
even enter those spaces.
So I think that you know, we're generally,
our voices are underrepresented
in certain sections
of the student population,
not across the board,
but there are certain
areas where you know,
the community could do better
in terms of listening to us
and having us involved.
And then to the point about mental health.
We as DEFY have partner with
a couple mental health groups
on campus so the Yale layer
is a publication that deals
with mental health and
mental illness on this campus
and we have worked with them.
We've gotten involved a little bit with,
formerly known as Mind Matters,
I don't know what their new name is,
but they're a group that promotes
mental well-being on campus.
You know we've worked some,
we've reached out to the
Walden peer counselors,
they do peer counseling for
students with mental illness
and we've tried in general
to be more inclusive
of students with mental illness.
So the peer mentor program
did a bunch of outreach
to get students with mental
illness more involved
and we do have quite a few
mentees whose diagnosis
are you know, mental health related.
So that is a huge and growing part of our
undergraduate advocacy community,
as well as those of mental illness.
- [Janni] I think we have time
for a couple more questions.
Is there anybody else?
- [Mary] Hi my name's Mary,
I'm a rehabilitation
physician by training,
but Yale School of Public
Health three years ago.
I think this was an
excellent seminar today
and really appreciate the candidness
of all of our, of our moderator
and all of our speakers.
So thank you very much for that.
I think this is a great start.
I think this is opening
up the conversation
here in the Yale community.
I think in the state of Connecticut
and even nationally we
can do so much more.
Mentioning that next year
is the 30th anniversary
of the ADA, you know perfect
opportunity I think for Yale.
Through cross school collaboration,
to have a longer seminar
to talk about these issues.
So I'll throw that out there for,
I would love to participate
in that by the way.
I work in New Haven now not for Yale,
but I think it's an
opportunity, thank you.
- Great idea, thank you.
One last question anybody?
- [Attendee] Hi good afternoon
thank you so much for that.
That discussion it was fantastic.
I like my neighbor was really impressed
by what you said Sara.
About you know, a world where
your office is not needed.
And so when I think about
destigmatizing disability,
one of the major opportunities,
I see as a rehabilitation physician,
is recreation and sports.
I think there's very
few things that are more
galvanizing, cohesive,
and completely empowering.
And so I was just
wondering, in your office,
how many students who have disabilities
or who identifies having a disability,
come to you looking for recreation
opportunities on campus,
and what are those opportunities?
And if there aren't that many,
how do you think that might change?
And this can go to either Paige or Sarah.
- So that's an interesting
question because
in the last year or so,
I think we've seen that coming
up more and more and more.
I think that the biggest
way that my office interacts
with student athletes is after an injury.
(crowd laughs)
We have met the entire women's rugby team.
(laughs)
So you know I think that,
that there's a good awareness
of what we do generally
in the student athlete community.
We've gotten questions recently
about the accessibility of
the pool at Payne Whitney,
and things like that.
I've recently been opening up connections
with administrators in
the gym to work on issues
about accessibility.
I think that there's a
lot of room for growth
but like so many other things,
there is definitely,
all the attitudinal pieces are in place.
It's just kind of figuring
out how do we make everything
as accessible as it can be.
Paige might have more information
from a student perspective though?
- Honestly not really.
I've, you know, I've
noticed a lot of students
are trying to get more involved,
especially intramurals
because they're competitive,
but less so.
That's sort of like a
team bonding experience
in your residential college,
and I think that that creates
more community cohesion
which then makes students
with various disabilities
more likely to pursue
intramurals as a welcoming space.
I've also noticed that you know,
some club sports like
there's clubs swimming
and things like that,
are probably more accessible,
but I haven't seen individuals
going those routes.
So for the last two years
I was on a club sport.
I was on the climbing team,
and I would love to see
something like adaptive climbing,
because I know that it exists,
and I would love it if we
could bring it to this campus.
I think there are a lot of opportunities
for improvement in that regard,
and since there are so many
club and intramural sports,
I think there's a lot of different ways
in which this campus could have
more inclusive opportunities
for students with disabilities to
partake in recreational activities.
- [Janni] Thank you so much.
So I think we've got, we're
probably out of time for today.
I think all of us will be
here for a little while,
at least in case you have
more questions or comments
that you would like to share with us.
I want to take this opportunity
to thank every one of our panelists,
to thank Henry for putting
this remarkable group together,
and maybe leave us all with
a message from my mentor,
Professor John Morton Blum,
who may be as famous for his cameo
on the Woody Allen movie, Zelig,
as he was for his history courses,
in 20th century American history.
When he said, above all,
think, act, be, in the active tense.
Thank you so much.
(crowd applause)
- You did a great job.
- Yeah.
(soft bells tune)